everybody welcome back to proven real I
know it's been quite a while since I've
put out a video and I apologize for that
I know when we left off I was doing the
steampunk series where I was making some
steampunk stuff and I was going to make
some steampunk guns I didn't get a
chance to finish up that series and I
felt kind of bad about it
and I still don't have time actually to
do a build today but I thought I would
talked about some of the props that you
guys see behind me one of the very first
kind of steampunk style Regan's I made
was this one here and I was I think at
comic-con several years ago and I saw
over the Wetty
booth and they were set up and they had
their dr. gourd warts ray guns and stuff
set up and I just thought they were
beautiful I mean the excellent design by
Gregg Broadmoor and you know at the time
I would have loved to have purchased
some but I was pretty broke or at least
I didn't have the money to spend
frivolously on on things like that
so it really inspired me to go home and
and see what I could make just using
some of the junk and stuff like that I
had lying around I kind of took that
challenge on and decided to make my own
set of ray guns and that actually kind
of led into a whole other project that I
wound up doing or working on that I'm
actually still working on today and it's
kind of a long process but this was one
of the first ray guns that I made the
body of it is an electrical connector
box just a two-port and I left the top
open and popped in a PVC pipe with a cap
and some fake rivets held it all
together with plumber's putty and the
handle was - a cheap dollar store car
chamois or something like that not that
I just cut off and cut off the bottom of
the box and insert it in there shot some
screws in it and because the the
electrical boxes are they hollow I
actually put like a toy gun trigger
mount inside there with the springs and
stuff like that so it
we kind of you know press depress the
the trigger and it kind of works and
then as the piece of I think it was
maybe aluminum strapped that I used for
the trigger guard and screwed it in and
then the barrel consists of a piece of
conduit with some washers conduit
connector and then that and here this is
just off of a flashlight broken
flashlight and this part here is the
stem off of our cartridge off of a
metering like shower handle and he had a
bunch of I was replaced them all the
time at my old job and I thought they
kind of look cool and be a good part to
something else and so that was just the
end of it and then this part here is a
lawnmower muffler and it was kind of it
was threaded on one end and it actually
fit perfectly into the threads on the
electrical connector box so yeah and
this other parts are just pieces of
plastic that I filled with some putty to
kind of keep more rigid and some pieces
of tubing and wire wall anchor the phony
dial there I just drew up and yeah I
mean that's a that's about it it's you
know a bunch of got a piece of brass
elbow there but that was it it was just
kind of an organic process I was finding
parts and I thought then this is the
cool I think I could use this and I just
kind of cobbled it together and yeah he
just repurposed them and you know give
him another paint job and it becomes a
pretty cool looking Arabia you know the
second one that I did was a little bit I
did a little bit more kind of
freestyling I guess on this one though
the handle I made I cut out of a piece
of wood and then I sculpted the design
sort of on the handle of the grip with
some plumber's putty and the body of
this one came from a buddy of mine
was thrown away a bunch of toy bowling
pins from like a child's toy bowling pin
set or bowling set and so I thought
there's a look was was perfect for kind
of the design I wanted to go for a very
retro looking Raygun and so that was the
body of it is just a kids bowling pin
with the end cut off and a piece of pipe
added to it with some connectors and
another electrical conduit connector
with some tightening rods on it some
just wire some hard some rigid wire that
I bent in for the piping and again this
like a wall anchor and some grease
fittings but I just glued on there and
yeah the little the top piece is
actually another electrical connector
box and this time I mean I just kind of
glued some pieces on to it the back is
again some washers just done different
sizes so whatever so Tennant gives that
reduction and the trigger actually is
like a keychain that kind of depressed
or whatever it was had a little spring
in it so then I sculpted the trigger
itself and inserted it into the wooden
handle that I made was very kind of
presses and then this was a piece of I
think copper pipe that I just cut it in
half and opened up and then that became
the trigger guard and then the vial back
here I had a bunch of these vials from I
think American science and surplus or
most hobby shops like practically any
hobby shop you go to will have a series
of like little little glass bottles and
stuff like that you can buy and that's
all that that is and I added some
plumber's putty and a little fitting at
the end and some copper wire just to
kind of give it that look and you know
fill it up with some Gatorade I could
you know just use water and some food
coloring and creating either colors and
stuff that you wanted but
when I was shooting I wound up shooting
a little bit of a short film with these
and I didn't have the the gun totally
completed yet I was kind of building it
on set and so then I just went down to
they had like a little cafe and I
grabbed a bottle of Gatorade and they
had blue was what they had so that
that's the color and I thought it looked
kind of cool it was kind of a neat look
the little dial here is kind of crappy I
would actually probably replace that if
I were to do anything with these again
but again it was it was a fun exercise
and building something completely and
still kind of haunting to a specific
design so that it looks kind of like a
cool you know very vintage style
steampunk like looking Raygun so I mean
is the kind of thing like that
I would hope inspires you to just go out
and start building stuff you don't need
you know a lot of we don't need
professional materials specifically you
know like just finding objects that you
think look cool or interesting that you
can repurpose and turn them into
something else doing that it is always a
lot of fun instead it's different than
having a specific design and building
that specific design if you have the
ability to do that and the materials to
do that that's a very important skill to
have you know because of you're working
in the industry then you're gonna be
working with directors and producers and
stuff like that and they're you're gonna
have a very specific idea of how they
want the design to look and then you
have to match that exactly but a lot of
times then if you're just creating like
background props and stuff like that but
they still have to look interesting and
cool and you have to build them quick
and cheap a good skill to have is it's
kind of taking bits and pieces of other
leftover parts and putting something
together and making something completely
new and it kind of hones your skills
kinda keeps you sharp when you're
working with a lot of when you have
access to a line of those different
materials or if you're like pulling
stuff off the shelf
you're like I actually that looks cool I
could use that for this or you know that
plumbing part looks kind of need if I
totally repurpose it and just use that
part for this another part for this and
because sometimes that the elements
become very recognizable unless you hide
within another object and you know
repaint it and other things it kind of
becomes very obvious that you know like
this is an electrical box or that this
is a piece of and conduit connector and
stuff but yeah this spacesuit once I I
built the ray guns and I kind of put the
time and I was happy with what they
turned out I thought it'd be fun to make
a little short film and then then
actually kind of escalated into a whole
series that I'm kind of still working on
hopefully one day I'll have an
opportunity to share with you guys but
this one I know people have inquired
about this giant diving helmet thing
this and actually it's it's a spacesuit
my head actually comes out or the ecers
head comes out here and and so it
basically comes up to like here like my
nose kind of an eyes fit in it and so
I've got this piece so I can breathe and
this is just a door stopper with piece
of plumber's putty on the tip there but
the the overall design kind of started
from from this I found this dome as a
irrigation dome I had a nurse door and
part of a planter and that's the
irrigation dome and it was like 2 bucks
or something like that and I was like I
gotta build a spacesuit around this dome
so initially what I did so initially
this was actually I just got another
planter and cut it so that it would fit
like this and then I was gonna add stuff
to it
I would have to have some kind of way to
reduce it so that the dome would fit on
top of this and that was in the process
of making this be the top her the suit
and I realized I needed to get something
that would connect the dome to it so I
was gonna go to a party store and get
just a cheap punch bowl and cut out the
top and then use that and I could stick
my head through and put the dome on and
when I walked in it was like early
September and they already had their
Halloween stuff out and I saw this big
cauldron
that they were selling for like 12 bucks
it was super cheap and so that's all
this is is a cauldron that I turned
upside down and I cut a hole out of the
top of my head I still bought the punch
bowl and put that as the top part and
cut out these pieces for my arms and
yeah I did I cut out the center piece
and added like the tap light or whatever
so it has that kind of you know now
Jules Verne sort of style it does look
like a like a diving helmet
but that's the idea is that looked kind
of like big and cumbersome and iron and
then like the breathing apparatus in the
back is a couple of shampoo bottles with
some brass piping and a little handle
and a gauge that I had lying around and
yeah once you throw some phony rivets on
it and give it a paint job it becomes
kind of a cool space see let's see if I
can still put it on
yeah I went through like that and then I
had a like a jumpsuit that I wander
Neath it and it was like this piece
actually here was the torso and that
kind of fits underneath this and then
I'm I was able to kind of rotate like
this and French like that overall it was
very it's a very cumbersome and very
awkward costume to wear but it looked
kind of cool on film if you go to my
facebook page actually you can see that
I've got some pictures of when we were
shooting the initial kind of test
footage with it and yeah then this
actually the piece I was going to be on
the top turned out to be like the
codpiece that the whole piece rests on
and then I made some cheap foods and
stuff and yeah so then that kind of
became my steampunk Victorian style
spacesuit yeah hopefully I'll finish the
project one day and I can share with you
guys yeah so then I I made a few more
ray guns that it kind of looked more so
that kind of prompted me to further the
design and make some more dieselpunk
sort of style or I'm a big fan of of the
early Flash Gordon and Buck Rogers movie
serials and so that kind of sort of
transitioned the project into that kind
of style so using the the kids bowling
pins or whatever I made another really
cheap I just turned the bowling pin the
other way and cut off the back and just
edit again some washers and there's some
what I use to separate them was just a
piece of aluminum tubing that I just cut
into pieces and shot a screw through it
to kind of hold everything tight and
then again it's just some plumber's
putty on the end there a piece of
plastic with some holes drilled out on
the top for the fin
and it was like a plastic hanger that
you adhere to the back of a door or
something who is at a dollar store and
then a child's I think was like a squirt
gun handle or something that I did sand
it down and repurposed with some I added
some plumber's putty and stuff like that
to it to give it another shape their
overall shape to make it look a little
bit more like a 1950's kind of Raygun
here's another one
this one while I was filming I decided I
wanted to have kind of a 50s sort of
style or 40s 50s to kind of style rayko
really it's it's modeled after sort of
the Flash Gordon serials there's like a
pretty iconic shadow Flash Gordon and
Dale Arden like this like in Cameron
he's got this ridiculous looking ray gun
and it was very much kind of modeled
after that style I also wanted to model
it sort of in the vein of like a
Thompson submachine gun sort of like
this kind of element here kind of came
through to handle everything but yeah I
threw together in about an hour and a
half using some bits and pieces that I
had yeah this is like a thrift store I
think it's some kind of like espresso an
espresso machine or something like that
I don't know I yeah was it's a there
shake well before using okay
I don't know but yeah so that's what the
body of it was and then the back is a
hairdryer was all plumbed pieces I used
chrome pieces that I wanted to have that
finish and instead of chroming it myself
I just used bits and pieces of stuff
that I had that already had a chrome
kind of finish to it this was just an
old shower rod I think and this is a
shower head and
body of it was just cheap word that I
cut the handle and stuff into and then
the top is yeah just a piece of plastic
again that I just cut and shaped real
quick
but yeah it's overall it gives kind of a
neat very iconic sort of retro sci-fi
look and it kind of has a neat sort of
feel to on-screen it's like it looked
really neat the one problem was I shed a
lot of green screen stuff and the when
you have stuff that's very reflective
it's really hard to key so I would
recommend possibly dirtying up a bit if
you're gonna shoot stuff doing green
screen but do you otherwise
maybe they'll save those for another
time this episodes already gotten
probably a little bit longer than you
have any patience for something Oh
actually you know one more thing I
actually going to talk about this how
that I've gotta let people talk about
though I do what is that rock The
Rocketeer style helmet that you have
there and again it's all the same
project and it was really I know it has
kind of a Rocketeer look
but the The Rocketeer helmet and that
whole design was very closely modeled
after a lot of other kind of movie
serial type characters like Buck Rogers
and Flash Gordon and spice masher and
stuff like that and really this this
design that I used was modeled after
Buck Rogers comic book and it had this
very specific type of look I gave it the
the paint job that kind of lends itself
a little bit more to that Rocketeer kind
of style but yeah it's a very Art Deco
kind of piece and again I was super
cheap I wanted to make the helmet I had
the idea for the design of my head and
so I went to a costume shop and they had
Centurion helmet like a Roman centurion
helmet and I was like that's pretty
close I think that's close enough or as
close as I'm gonna get to the helmet I
want and it's really cheap being I did I
again I was trying to build it but it's
very little to no money so I think that
that's ensuring helmet was maybe like 12
bucks and it was really made a comic a
cheap plastic but when I heated it it
was able I could actually kind of reform
it a little bit so I wound up cutting
off the back of the helmet that kind of
swooped out I didn't like that design
and I didn't want it to look too much
like a century gnome and I took the
crust off the top with the plume and
everything and then replaced it with
again is the piece of plastic that I cut
and then to give it some texture or
layers I just added another piece here
that was made out of craft foam and then
the ear pieces are just craft foam
cutting the circles and then reshaped
kind of give it that rounded kind of
feel and the back is craft foam I have a
kind of just several pieces that I glued
and that sort of reduces the helmet
kinda brings it back in and makes it a
little bit more form-fitting and then
again using some craft or some this is a
foam man actually that I built the jaw
piece out of its kind of falling apart
now but it would snap in like that and I
had the the chin piece actually has a
elastic strap I had the to it so I could
talk and stuff like that I wasn't
restricted but it also was still held
its shape and its form and then I could
also talk and it would move around and
stuff like that yeah I think that's
about it for today I've got a few more
pieces and stuff like that but I'll
probably go into more that next time or
hopefully I'm when the project kind of
ramps up again maybe I'll I'll show you
guys a little bit more
of the actual project and some of the
footage that I shot so yeah I don't know
that's it I get that's all I got time
for today but hopefully next time very
soon I will have another episode where I
build something so once again thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time